well the first challenge is I'm just
facing an incredibly strong opponents I
mean even in the very strong tournaments
that I'm playing where guys are let's
say twenty six fifty to twenty seven
hundred or even beyond like I just
played in Hainan like Maxime is just
stronger than any of them so the first
challenge is just that I'm playing
against someone absurdly strong and
frankly just a much better chess player
than I am he's a huge favorite of course
but if the favorites always won chest
would be a really boring game and I hope
I showed the US Championship that's not
always the case even if it took me ten
tries yeah some hasbunallah turns is
huge just me and i guess it was a good
time for him because I know the feelings
I know that for some years it was at
least his results didn't show it was
improving and then all of a sudden he
got his his breakthrough I mean
something clicked and yeah I mean I know
exactly how that feels and so that makes
him of course a very very dangerous
opponent and yeah what are you looking
for what against him well I'm not gonna
treat him any differently than I would
treat anybody else I came ready to play
I just wanted to make sure I was
training trying to get as good as I
could at Fischer random play as much to
my strengths as I can and not worry
about playing to his strengths or
weaknesses and just trying to play my
best dress I've sort of got that new
attitude of only focus on what you can
control it is very surprising sometimes
to see you know our players do a chess
960 and I am incapable of predicting our
will first
I'm gonna try and guess my other players
including my opponent sound fair to me
I'm just gonna try to focus on the moves
and I think you'll provide a lot more
resistance than a lot of other people in
lights but ultimately if you play a
perfect game you're gonna win that's
always the case now most of the time
you're not going to play a perfect game
at all so you should be shooting for
you